- He don't care, you
don't come back short,
you come back with it all,
or you get your ass whooped,
and I mean, whooped.
And you gotta go right back
out there, he don't care.
It doesn't matter to him,
cause he sit back like a pimp,
to wait, while we out
there laying on our back,
sucking dick, you know what I'm saying?
And getting fucked, wherever.
When I was 17, I had
been put in the trunk.
I was walking down the street.
I was on Elscondo Main,
and I got on Broadway
and I turned the corner
and I seen the car.
And he pulled over and he
said like the nice guy,
you know, he was clean cut and tie
and you know, dressed nice
and asked me to get in,
and I did, you know.
Even took me out to eat and
went to a bar, everything.
Then when I told him, you know,
okay, I'm ready to go home.
You know, we can keep
in touch or whatever.
He turns the other way.
And I'm like, where are we going?
Don't worry about it.
You know what I'm saying?
And ended up in a factory.
And I seen these knives
on the side of his, you know, on his side.
It was not like one, it
was two or three of 'em.
You know what I'm saying?
And I, I had got kind of
nervous and he locked the door.
I'm like, well, what are
you locking the door for?
He said, don't worry about it, bitch.
And what, you know, all
the time, I'm thinking,
you know, I'm gonna die.
He's fixing to kill me.
But I had time enough to get out
because he was always,
he was reaching this way.
'Cause he asked me to take off my clothes,
and as I was like playing
like I was gonna take 'em off.
I was trying to unlock the door,
but he was steadily on the side,
you know, getting the knives
and luckily I just
unlocked it and got out,
but he snatched me and I pulled from him
and I ran and he was running after me.
He was running after me with the knife.
And luckily when I came up to a alleyway
it was three men that was
working at the factory.
They was outside and I was hollering.
And they really didn't
pay too much attention
as me running down the street,
but he had stopped when he seen them
and turned back around
and went and got in his car and left.
So I had just ran, just kept running.
And you know, I had my
shoes in my hand, everything
and I kept running, but I never
told anyone this, you know.
And after that it was just,
it was a bad experience then.
And then another time,
I was on Fig, Figueroa,
nice looking
you know, whatever, you know,
dumb, gonna try it again.
And I did.
And we talked or whatever,
it always started good.
But then it don't.
He took me to his house.
Oh yeah, took me to his house.
Nice home sat, drank, whatever.
And then he was like,
do you like kinky stuff?
And I'm like, well, not really, but okay.
You know, I'll try it.
You know?
So he tied me to the bed.
I'm like, okay, but you're
not gonna tie my ankles.
And he was like, no, but then
after awhile I was feeling kind of drowsy.
You know, like if he puts
something in the drink,
which he did,
and I just like passed out,
and next thing I woke up,
I was on the sidewalk by the bus stop.
'Cause I had passed out on the drink.
So, you know, everything was over,
you know, he had set me on a bus stop
and then I had woke up.
'Cause when I woke up I was laying
on the bus stop on the bench,
and I woke up and I don't
know what drug he gave me
or whatever, but I was still kind of,
you know, drowsy from the drug.
And I found my way home,
you know, staggering and whatever.
And it's just, you know, it's been wrong.
And then my finger right
here that got broke.
It was from another time.
I was in a park.
It was somebody I knew,
somebody I knew,
and we were there drinking,
you know, on a bench.
And he asked me to do something with him,
and I told him no.
So he took my arm, turns it around.
And he said, bitch,
I'll break your finger.
And I kept telling him no,
and I was trying to get away,
but I couldn't 'cause he was big
and he broke it.
He broke my finger.
And I had just, I don't know.
I knew him.
But the ones you know
don't always be the
ones you think you know.
But yeah.
- [Interviewer] Your
experience that first time was,
hey, this is easy money.
- I needed money.
Oh, this not gonna happen again.
But it did.
I'm gonna try this one more time.
And this was someone I
knew, he broke my finger.
I did it another time.
It's just been bad.
- [Interviewer] Well, what is it
about this lifestyle that
attracts so many women?
Is it, you don't need an education?
- The money.
- [Interviewer] You
don't need the education.
You don't need anything other
than just to show up in a skirt.
- The money, the looks, the body,
you know,
the attitude, everything,
the strut, just everything,
you know, the clothes.
- [Interviewer] It's just an
easy way to make a fast buck?
- You know, all that,
you know what I'm saying?
All they want is they money.
You know, I wanted to try it.
This person I knew, he he wanted to like,
okay, I'll be with you.
You know?
But I had second thoughts.
I was like, no, because
I know how they are.
You know?
And plus the experience I'd been through,
who needs a pimp?
You know what I mean?
I get a pimp, he gonna do the same thing
if I don't bring all the money.
This other man.
I was down, I was in Inglewood.
I walk in, seen each other talk.
Now he took what he wanted from me,
and then bust my mouth.
I got no teeth.
Didn't give me nothing.
Just took what he wanted.
I don't know.
He was kind of, I don't know, crazo.
- [Interviewer] A lot of girls get,
they seem to get addicted to this life.
- I was at the time I was, I was young.
I was naive,
you know what I'm saying, you know,
this is gonna be better than it was then.
It's gonna be better than what I was in.
You know, I'm thinking that, you know
I come along towards a
person that's with me
but then I was looking
in the wrong places.
Even though the lifestyle I was living,
what wrong place could you look?
I mean, everywhere you go
it's gonna be wrong somewhere,
but all the time it was wrong.
- [Interviewer] Looking back,
how many years did you do it?
Are you still doing?
- I kind of slowed down.
I slowed down, but it
it's been since I was 17.
I stopped when I was
like, hmm, I don't know.
34, you know?
- [Interviewer] But looking
back at your career,
did you save money?
Was it a good?
- Really not, no, I really didn't.
I have all clothes, all drugs,
you know what I'm saying?
Cigarettes, whatever I needed, you know.
- [Interviewer] It's
just the way to survive.
- Yeah.
That's all I was doing is surviving.
So what I get the money,
I'll get what I needed, what I wanted,
what I seen and didn't
have money and get it.
You know what I'm saying?
That I have.
- [Interviewer] A lot of the girls
and a lot of the pimps tell me that,
oh, we're making thousand dollars a night.
- Oh yeah, I was.
You know what I'm saying?
I was.
- [Interviewer] How much
were you making at nights?
- I don't know.
$300, $400 that wasn't nothing.
- [Interviewer] Do you think
that's a more realistic number
than the numbers I get very often?
- No.
- [Interviewer] You think girls make more?
- Yes.
Very much so.
The whole point is when
you working for someone,
what you get?
You get nothing.
You know what I mean?
When you out there in the streets,
laying on your back all night,
shoes in your hand,
and walking the streets all night, tired.
What you do?
you gotta come and give it to him.
You know what I'm saying?
Then you gotta get back out there.
It was not enough.
It was not what he wants.
You know what I mean?
And then if it's not what he want,
he said he gonna beat your ass.
He don't care.
He just want his money.
You know, he, that's all he wants.
Yeah, he may feed you, clothe you,
get you high, whatever.
But you gotta get back out
there until you have his money.
He don't, he don't care.
You don't come back short.
You come back with it all,
or you get your ass whooped.
And I mean whooped, you know?
And you gotta go right back out there.
He don't care.
It doesn't matter to him.
Cause he sit back like a pimp.
So wait.
Why we out there laying
on our back, sucking dick?
You know what I'm saying?
Getting fucked all in wherever, you know,
whatever it takes to get this man money.
- [Interviewer] What is
it that gets the women
like brainwashed into doing this?
Because it doesn't seem to make sense.
- Convincing?
Convincing.
His talk, you know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] They
seduce you into thinking
that it's something more?
- Things he say, things he say.
He can say, you know,
hey, you know, I like you,
you know, convince you in.
As you get convinced in,
and you go by what he's saying,
and you like what he's saying to you
you know the words he say,
you take them, oh, he liked me.
You know what I'm saying?
He want me to move with him.
But all the time he wants
you to do others for him.
But this is how he gets you in.
But you know what I'm saying?
You can come live with me.
You know?
I like you, you know what I'm saying?
I do everything for you.
But as he stray you in with them words,
and you go for it, it's others.
Have you ever, you know
have you ever thought, you
know, making money or whatever?
Well how?
You know, we'll make a little
money for me, you know?
Okay, all right.
Which I know, it's wrong,
but it's not wrong
because I liked this man.
You know what I'm saying?
He likes me.
You know what I mean?
So I'm gonna do whatever
he want me to do for him.
You know what I'm saying?
To make him happy.
And it goes to that, you know?
And it's sad
when I know I should have
been doing other things
with my life,
but I choose to do that
because of the money.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] I talked
to a few hundred of
- They're all fine.
I was fine with it, yeah.
- [Interviewer] I've
talked to a couple hundred,
like 200 or 300 girls that have done this,
and not a single one has come back
and said, yeah, he gave me a lot of money
at the end.
- But he looked out, he dress, whatever,
gave me $100, $200 for me.
But I had one thing, I
had to get back out there.
You know, regardless of what he gave me
I still had to go lay on my back,
suck dick, fuck in the ass, everything.
Or I get my ass beat, you understand?
I couldn't come short.
I couldn't say okay, big
daddy, I only made a thousand,
when I supposed to make $2000.
I get slapped, you know,
just get my ass beat
and get back out there.
So I wouldn't come back until I had it.
If it took me two or three days,
half of the night, half of the morning.
I wouldn't come back
because I know when I come and
ain't gonna be nothing else.
So when I do come back with the money
it's just here and that's it.
- [Interviewer] There's no way to get out?
- No, not really, no.
I mean you can,
but you have to look
behind you all the time,
because I'm the one
that's making the money.
- [Interviewer] You can't
work the street anymore.
- No.
I can't be seen really,
because he has people out there, you know?
You see that bitch,
you get her and bring her to me.
I don't know what's gonna happen.
He can kill me, beat my ass more.
Have him beat me, have him kill me.
I don't know.
So there's really no way out.
There's really no way out.
And the only way I got out, he died.
That's how I got out.
He died of cancer.
Other than that
I'd probably still be in the game,
still be in, right now.
If he was still here.
Because you know, the pimps don't play.
The pimps is with it.
You know what I'm saying?
He don't give a fuck how
old, what you got to do.
'Cause they ain't got to.
You just get out there
and get my money and come on
back and give it, you know?
And that's it, and that's all.
If you don't, you get your ass kicked.
You know, you do,
then I'll be nice.
I'll make you happy.
You know what I mean?
If he don't got what he wants,
you ain't getting nothing.
You know, probably get a piece of bread,
probably get a dollar two, maybe more.
But you know, he want his money,
and that's what it's about.
I done seen him
tie this girl up
this ho,
in the chair because she
came back with nothing.
Nothing.
Well, I couldn't make it, it was slow.
I couldn't get no clients.
Told this little boy to tie her up,
put a sheet over her,
and whipped her with a baseball bat.
And told her to get back
out there and get his money.
So that coulda happened to me.
That's why it's hard to get out.
It's hard.
but why would you not
come back with his money?
Knowing the type of things he'll do.
If it's not tying you up,
beat your ass with a bat,
he gonna beat your ass
with his hands, you know?
But you come back with nothing.
Come on.
Even if you came back with half of it,
he still would've beat your ass,
because that's not what he wanted.
He want all his money.
But they tied her up,
put a sheet over her,
and took her back and beat her ass.
And then he told her to go back
on the streets and get his money.
And she did.
It's hard.
It's hard because you're gonna get found.
If you try to get out of
it, if you try to run away,
if you try to just not be with it no more,
you gonna get found.
And it's not gonna be a pretty thing.
- [Interviewer] And the young
girls don't figure this out?
- You know, they know, I know.
You know right from wrong,
you know this is not
right anyway in your life,
you know what I'm saying?
But somehow that's the choice you made.
You think it's glamorous,
you think it's cool, but it's really not.
Because as you live in it and go about it,
you'll soon found out I'm
getting my ass whooped,
I gotta lay on my back every night,
I can't come home without
his money and all his money.
If I don't, I'll be sitting in a chair,
tied up with a sheet,
get beat, or him beat me.
Them the consequences.
You know what I'm saying?
So why ask why, you know?
That's how the life is.
And like I said, look,
you know, I was lucky.
'Cause he had died from cancer.
He was sick then, but not sick, sick,
but he was starting to
lose weight, you know,
starting not to be high.
He was, you know, be slower at things.
And I wasn't the first one.
He had another prostitute,
but I didn't see that.
He told them to take her in the
room and tie her to the bed.
All I heard was her holler,
what they did, I don't know.
She comes out and she had to
go back out on the street.
'Cause she only gave half of the money.
He don't want that.
He want all of it.
If you don't get all of his money
why the fuck you come back?
This man is not playing.
You know, he got people
that's gonna come out there
and seek and find you
no matter where you are.
They'll even come to your families.
You know what I'm saying?
'Cause that's how he is.
He was a older man.
- [Interviewer] But certainly
by now pimps have a reputation
similar to what you're describing.
- But by me have just getting in the game,
and getting to know him.
I mean I knew I was, if it wasn't right,
I'm gonna look for something,
but the shit I seen, I knew
I had to get out of it.
- [Interviewer] But they sweet talk you,
and seduce you early on?
- Yes, of course.
Yeah, of course.
That goes with it, yeah, yeah.
But you know, somehow I
had to get out of this.
I didn't know how, when I seen that happen
then when I seen, you know,
them take her in the room,
I'm saying, Trish, you got to get out.
You got to get out of this.
How, I don't know.
I don't know how, but not saying
I was glad that he passed,
but that was the only way.
That was the only way out.
And I did, I got out.
And didn't look back.
Mm hmm, and sometimes it crossed my mind.
Sometimes it does.
Okay, Tricia, go on out
there and try again.
Maybe, you know, probably seen
something that's worth it.
Just like I thought then,
then I get, you know,
kind of second thoughts
and say, no, no, don't, don't go there.
You know?
Cause it might be the same and it may not.
But then you never know.
Cause you got crazies out here.
You do.
You got crazies out here.
You do, you really do.
And another time, this
man took me in a factory,
these factories,
and tried to rape me.
Luckily, the police was coming
to patrol the factories.
I hollered, they came, got him,
and he had a rap sheet of that,
of rape and whatever and took him to jail.
But he was feeling really,
you know, he was raping me.
He was tearing off my
clothes and everything.
Luckily I seen the police
and I hollered and they came,
shined they light,
and they got him out and took him to jail.
They said that's the
one we were looking for.
'Cause he'd been raping
prostitutes on Figaro
you know, but he he was
another clean cut guy,
nice tie, shirt, you know?
Okay, hey, everything.
Turned out to be, you know,
Chester Molester,
you know what I mean?
'Cause I was wondering why
we going in these factories?
You know, we could just turn around
and go through right here
on the corner an alley.
But you know, it's been
an experience, you know.
You know my finger,
my, you know,
it's just been rough, you know?
I didn't wake up until now, you know.
I realized, but I be
sometimes it crosses mind,
sometimes it cross the mind,
to where I, go on back out there, Tricia.
Maybe you'll find them nice white man.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] Is that always
a dream for these girls?
Is that maybe you'll find
some Prince Charming?
Richard Gere's gonna come by.
- For me, yeah, for me, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
I've heard it before.
He can, you know, he can pimp me.
(laughing)
But other than that, yeah.
It's just been, it's crazy, you know,
but that's just the experience
you have to go through.
You know, when you're out
in your life like that,
and living a life like that, you know?
So it's really no why ask why,
it's just why, you know?
But it is what it is.
But it just was an experience for me.
That's all I'd like to say.
- [Interviewer] Thank you so
much for sharing your story.
- Oh, you're welcome, you're very welcome.
- [Interviewer] I'm glad you survived.
- I'm glad I did too, hmm hmm.